Scott's with us in Orlando Florida hey
Scott welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
transy how are you better than I deserve
what's up I am a new listener and a
couple times I've heard events and how
is that to lease a car and my mom sees
grease I think over last three cars or
something like that and I was just
curious as to why you think that well
leasing is just another form of
financing a car okay if you go borrow
the money at the bank or go borrow the
money from GMAC or whoever right from
Lexus credit and you pay payments on it
you've borrowed $30,000 for a $30,000
car and you pay payments on it for five
years or whatever right okay right if
you if you lease a car you're paying
payments on it and you've got the car
for five years and at the end of that
time you either write up a check for
whatever's left over
called the residual value and you get
the car or your hand on the keys back
okay right either way you are paying a
finance charge on the amount of money
you're using if you're borrowing the
money it's called interest and you have
an interest rate an APR an annual
percentage rate there's a Truth in
Lending statement you may have seen them
published at times that's usually like
an eight and a half by eleven and
there's two big numbers at the top with
a big line through them it covers about
a third of the page and another line and
below the third of the page is a whole
bunch of disclaimers and it tells you
what your actual cost of interest is
it's a federal Truth in Lending
statement when you borrow the money on a
car you get one of those have you ever
seen what those you know I'm talking
about yes and that's your first rate
that's your interest rate so it said you
know eight percent six percent two
percent whatever your actual interest
rate is on a lease it's not technically
under the law a loan so there's no
disclosure as to what you're paying for
the money interest is what you pay for
the money in a lease it's technically
called cost of capital but if you took a
financial calculator and you put in
there the value of the car the MSRP on
the car
at the beginning of the lease the
residual value at the end of the lease
the payments in the meantime you can
back out what your effective interest
rate is your cost of capital is it
usually comes out around 14% okay and so
when you do the actual math on a lease
it is the most expensive way to operate
an automobile okay that's why it's bad
okay and you don't even own the
automobile technically you're renting it
is what amounts to right but but that
doesn't matter and you don't get it
you're not missing out on the
depreciation because if a $30,000 car
you drive off the lot when you lease it
when you turn it back in if it's worth
ten you can be guaranteed that $20,000
drop in value is built into the payments
that you paid they're not gonna take the
loss in value they're gonna hand that to
you in those payments so you don't
escape of the gloss in value the
depreciation you pay a high cost for the
money that you're borrowing and it's all
an illusion and and yet 78% of the new
cars that leave the lot right now are
leased because the car companies make
more money on the lease than they do on
a borrowed deal and they make a lot more
money than they do with a guy like me
that pays cash for them and buys it at
invoice and I buy usually typically
right around invoice when I'm buying a
car and so that's the reason it's just
simply more expensive
and you know Wall Street Journal smart
money magazine Consumer Reports Dave
Ramsey
we've all done break downs and articles
on the lease showing that it's the most
expensive way to operate a car that's
why Scott hey thanks for the call it's a
really good question